[SINGING]
DAN LINKE : Can you tell me what was
there to love about Princeton?
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: Oh.
How can you ask?
It's been part of my
life since I was a kid.
It was a tremendous
feeling to have
responsibility for a place
as an important as Princeton.
ROBERT K. DURKEE: For
much of the 20th century,
Bob Goheen's life
was at Princeton.
And for a good portion of that
time, the life of Princeton
depended on Bob Goheen.
During his presidency,
the world's issues
became Princeton's issues.
In his guidance
was an inner voice,
which bore testimony to
Adlai Stevenson's observation
that in quiet places,
reason abounds.
Born in India to
medical missionaries,
he received his undergraduate
degree in classics in 1940,
and after a stint in the
Army, returned to earn
his Ph.D. in classics in 1948.
A mere nine years later,
in succeeding Harold Dodds,
he became at 37 the
third-youngest president
in Princeton's history.
REPORTER: WPRB presents
a special program devoted
to the selection of assistant
professor of classics
Robert F. Goheen as president
of Princeton University.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: After
the presidential search had
been going on a while, a
number of my faculty friends
say, we hear you're on the list.
And I said, well,
that's nonsense.
Why would they look at
a youngster like me?
ROBERT K. DURKEE:
Under the pretext
of wanting the views
of younger faculty,
the trustees asked Bob to meet.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: I
was completely relaxed.
I didn't think it
related to me at all.
I told them quite candidly
what I thought about Princeton
and what some of
its problems were
and what its tremendous
potential was
and about individuals
who I thought
would be or not be good
presidents, so I had a ball.
ROBERT K. DURKEE:
Some time later, Bob
was spending the
weekend in Connecticut
when he received an
unusual phone call.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: Mr. Helm
said, some of us trustees
would like to meet with you
Sunday morning in New York.
Can you make it?
And I said, Mr. Helm,
it's a great honor,
but right now I'm with
my roommate and his wife
and we don't get away
very often and can't it
be some other time?
And he said, no.
He said, I think it's important.
You better come.
REPORTER: Professor
Goheen's election
was announced by Harold
H. Helm, chairman
of the executive committee
of the University
Board of Trustees.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: There were
five trustees, the senior-most
of the trustees.
We chatted a little while and
he gave me a glass of sherry.
And they said they wanted me to
be president of the university.
I almost went through
the floor, but I
said, yes, I would try it.
EDWARD R. MURROW: He was
described by its predecessor
as an intellectual who can
hit 225-yard drives down
the fairway.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN:
If one believes
as intensely in the importance
of a liberal education
for our times as I do, then
Princeton is a wonderful place
to work for.
One of the most
senior and I must
say powerful Princeton
trustees said to me,
the University's in
great financial shape
and you won't have to spend
a lot of time raising money.
You can concentrate
on education.
Well, even as an
assistant professor,
I knew that wasn't the
way things were here.
Anything that you try to do
well is going to cost money.
I'm sure a good television
show, Mr. Murrow,
is an expensive operation.
Harvard took the lead and
boldly launched a $92 million
capital campaign, the
first thing of its kind
certainly in our times.
And that emboldened us to
start to work right away
and develop a capital
campaign, which
I guess we announced sometime
in late '58 or early '59,
for $53 million.
Then let's go out
to the Windy City.
DONALD: We report $2,496,000.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: Hooray!
Thank you, Donald.
God bless you.
You figure $53 million is
nothing in current currency.
But in the 1950s, it was a
hell of a whole lot of money.
ROBERT K. DURKEE: For some
perspective, $53 million
was about half the cost of the
Soviet Union's Sputnik space
program, the success of
which was on everyone's mind
when Goheen was interviewed
by Edward R. Murrow in 1958.
EDWARD R. MURROW: Dr. Goheen,
are you troubled at all
by the Sputnik-inspired
suggestions for crash
programs in the sciences?
REPORTER: Today, a new
moon is in the sky.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: I really do
believe that Sputnik generated
in America a much
renewed and heightened
sense of the importance
of higher education.
In the next 10 years
or so, resources
came to the universities
that had just been quite
out of their reach before.
These assets will
pay large dividends
for Princeton in
the years ahead.
REPORTER: President Goheen has
just made the opening address
to dedicate the new building
for the Woodrow Wilson
School of Public and
International Affairs.
CHANTING: Hip, hip, hip!
Sis, sis, sih!
Boom, boom, boom! Aaaah!
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: And so, ladies
and gentlemen, [INAUDIBLE], we
say thank you very much
indeed and good night.
I think I'd confess that
through most of my life,
until the early '60s, I had been
largely oblivious to the issue
of race in this country.
Then as these reports
started to come out
of the South about civil
rights activities there,
that led me to
try to see what we
could do to increase the racial
diversity on the Princeton
campus.
Not easy, because
as we found out,
blacks who might
academically be eligible many
turned away because
of its reputation
as having been a place which
rejected blacks, and not
the least because of Woodrow
Wilson's activity as president
in denying blacks entry
into the civil service.
That was a shocker.
Wilson had to me
always been a hero,
and was up until this time.
Then suddenly I
learned about what
he'd done with respect to
the blacks in Washington.
And I was clear he
was a Southern racist.
I saw that women were playing
an increasingly influential role
in this world.
We just were not in touch
with this whole segment
of our society that were going
to be influential players
in the society.
Princeton had fallen
behind in this respect.
STUDENT: If Princeton
doesn't have girls here,
it's going to lose out on the
top students in the nation.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: That was
an important factor for us.
We like to think we're
dealing with the future movers
and shakers of the country.
And for some to just refuse
to come and be educated here
for that reason
was a great shock.
I asked Howard Helm,
the ranking trustee,
the chairman of the
executive committee,
if he would head a
committee to study
the issue of co-education.
And Harold said, but
I don't believe in it.
And I said, Harold, I didn't
ask you to believe in it.
I asked you to study it.
REPORTER: Princeton
University in Princeton,
New Jersey today
announced the end
of its all-male
educational tradition.
STUDENT: It's like
making history.
I'm a pioneer.
DAN LINKE: In retrospect,
is there anything
you wish you could
have done differently?
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: I hate to
sound like President Bush,
because I think
things went well.
STUDENTS: (SINGING)
We like co-education.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: Diversity,
pushing the effort
to get more blacks
and other minorities
into the University body,
whether it be student body
or faculty, and then the women.
I think both of those changed
the character of Princeton
for the better.
Those are the things I'd be
most proud of, I think, yeah.
RICHARD NIXON: I have
concluded that the time has
come for action.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN:
Looking backwards,
I realize that my first
decade, from '57 to '67
was a wonderfully calm
time on the campus.
RICHARD NIXON: This is not
an invasion of Cambodia.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN:
It happened to be
this night the
University was receiving
a bunch of distinguished
Russian scientists.
Toward the end of the
evening in Prospect,
word came that the incursion
into Cambodia had occurred.
REPORTER: A packed crowd of over
2,300 persons in the Princeton
University Chapel.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN:
Immediately followed
by all kinds of noise
of people rallying,
people had come to the
chapel for a demonstration.
At that initial point, I had no
idea what kind of demonstration
it was going to be.
But I asked the Russians
if they wanted to go.
STUDENT: So instead of
going to our classes,
I say let's go into the streets,
not to burn this country down,
but to remake this country.
REPORTER: The reaction
on the campuses
was swift and predictable.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: And it
was madness, sort of unreal.
REPORTER: Princeton students
called for a nationwide student
strike.
STUDENT: We are on strike, yes.
That's very clear.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: I saw
the Russians quietly
remove themselves.
REPORTER: A rather disorganized
scene, as hundreds of people
turned to look at Princeton
President Robert Goheen.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: I sat there
and decided it certainly
was not the time for anybody
official to try to intervene.
It would just be a
travesty to try to do that.
REPORTER: When our
reporter proposed
that Goheen talk to us,
he seemed visibly shaken.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: I think
I've made my position
on the war clear many times.
I went from being
a quiet proponent
of that war to being a very
quite outspoken opponent of it.
I do not believe to strike
against the University
because it's the nearest
thing at hand makes any sense.
[BOOS]
We never completely closed
our doors academically.
And I thought that
was important.
ROBERT K. DURKEE: Two years
earlier the University
had implemented a
series of reforms
aimed at involving students
and faculty more actively
in the University's
decision-making.
In May of 1970, as some
campuses erupted in violence,
Princeton stayed peaceful.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: We had
two general assemblies
in Jadwin Hall, where
everybody from the University
and community were invited
to come and sound off.
And I think there was just a
healthy airing of frustration
and anger and so on.
Those in favor of the
amendment -- Mr. Canaan,
excuse me.
I didn't see your hand.
I also had 10 faculty meetings.
And that was quite
wonderful, because the core
of the Princeton faculty
really rallied around and took
all of this seriously.
PROFESSOR: I would like to
move that this faculty give you
a standing ovation.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN:
My only response
is that it's a great
faculty to work with,
just as it's a great
student body to work with.
ROBERT K. DURKEE:
In March of 1971,
Bob Goheen announced
his retirement,
saying the University would
profit from fresh leadership.
He left office in 1972 after 15
years as Princeton's president.
That year, he became president
of the Council on Foundations.
In January 1977, he became
president of the Edna McConnell
Clark Foundation.
Less than five months
later, however, he
was appointed
ambassador to India,
the country of his birth,
by President Carter.
I thought to be an ambassador
you had to either be very rich
or a very active member
of the political party
of your president.
I was neither rich nor was
I a political partisan,
so it was a nice
shock to be invited
in the sense just for me
because I knew something
about the country.
PROFESSOR: Dr. Tilghman,
please raise your right hand
and repeat after me.
I do solemnly swear --
SHIRLEY TILGHMAN: I
do solemnly swear --
ROBERT K. DURKEE: In 2001, 32
years after Princeton admitted
women on his watch,
Goheen participated
in installation ceremonies for
the University's first woman
president.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN: We
took in women students
quite a long time ago.
It was certainly time
to get more women
high in the administration.
And here she's headed right
at the top, which is great.
I for one today feel
full of good hope.
I don't know what
my legacy is, but I
might say that I was able
to start a process of change
in the University,
creative change, which
has been carried forward by
each one of my successors.
I don't know if that's
a legacy or not,
but anyhow it's very
gratifying to see
that the University's
not stopped and said,
now we've done it.
We’re there.
Let's just continue to
do what we were doing.
DAN LINKE: I just want to ask if
there's anything on your mind
that we haven't
discussed that you
want to record for posterity.
ROBERT F. GOHEEN:
I don't think so.
You've drawn me
out very well, Dan.
And we've talked
now for four hours.
And I think I've spilled
all the beans, as they say.